I left one thing out when I said that the .prototype objects that come for
free on functions were just as uninteresting as any other new object that we
could use for storing methods.
In fact, these prototype objects come with one
extra convenience property that almost no other object has.
Every .prototype object has a .constructor property which points back to
the function it came attached to.
Thus, there is a mutual linking between any new function and
it's companion .prototype object, because car links to .prototype object,
and prototype links back to the car object.
Car.prototype.constructor is car itself.
The main use for this feature is so
that you can figure out which constructor function built a certain object.
All instances of a class delegate their field lookups to their prototype,
and so they should all report as having the same constructor function.
What do you think would be logged as Amy's constructor property?